est en train d'arriver donc nous allons
bonjour madame Schiappa et merci d'être
avec nous je vous en prie vous
connaissez monsieur Geoffrin vous
connaissez madame Fulda vous connaissez
madame d'ornellade ça me fait très
plaisir que vous soyez là
ah bah oui on est en direct
bonjour alphabet Athènes Gabriel votre
thème est casse-tête
c'est parti le Premier ministre
[Musique]
le virus galope et vous tirez sur le
frein à main de pain c'est mesdames et
messieurs les députés nos soignants
engagés qui eux ne s'arrête pas à minuit
comme vous l'avez souhaité voter
c'est purement irresponsable à l'origine
de la colère du Premier ministre un vote
à main levée dans l'hémicyclier hier
soir au sujet de la poursuite des débats
sur le Pass vaccinal après minuit les
solutions que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui vont vous servir aussi pour
les lendemain de tête excusez
vous rendre compte que c'est assez
facile ça vous dérange pas
70 62 des mains se lèvent dans les
oppositions y compris au PS et chez les
républicains pourtant favorables au
passes vaccinales les députés de la
majorité eux ne sont pas tous présents
la suspension est votée en suspens
une douche froide pour le gouvernement
qui voulait aller vite sur ce texte
comprenez ça pourquoi on est des gens
parce que vous véhiculez la la
bien-pensance il y en a marre de la doxa
vous comprenez ça
après pour le moment on est calme mais
bientôt on va pas le rester calme vous
ne dites que des mensonges combien vous
touchez pour faire mon boulot des
injections les injections vous pensez
monsieur je suis payé par les
laboratoires pour faire mon travail et
vous vous êtes corrompus comme c'est pas
possible citer les gens au vaccin qui a
donc bien pu vouloir dire ce député à
Olivier Véran aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
aujourd'hui il y aurait 15000 médecins
de plus dans le pays 15000 vous imaginez
combien de réalisateurs ça nous fait en
plus
vite en se dépêche de ce ministre on va
être en retard ou et dis donc Jean de
SEDAL je mangerai bien des pâtes moi des
spaghettis à moins qu'il ne s'agisse de
la troisième proposition à laquelle tout
le monde pense mais que la décence
m'interdit de dire à une heure de grande
écoute il vient de dire quelque chose à
faire une déclaration Emmanuel Macron et
non vacciné j'ai très envie de les
emmerder donc on va continuer de le
faire jusqu'au bout hein
c'est d'enlever c'est dans le cadre
enchaîner exactement
[Rires]
c'est pas très marrant non
[Musique]
vous connaissez bien monsieur Veyran
j'imagine et Monsieur dupont-mory il va
vouloir direz vous leur direz vous
devriez venir
ils sont un peu ils ont pas le cerveau
vous voyez souple quand même mais non
mais
c'est des balles dominants vous voyez
dans qui sont pas contents ah ben vous
voyez on est d'accord là dessus nous
aussi nous avons beaucoup de mal à nous
concentrer le journaliste du gardien
Johan Harry a enquêté donc pendant trois
ans sur ce sujet et dans son prochain
livre concentration volé il raconte
qu'aujourd'hui les étudiants n'arrivent
pas à se concentrer sur une tâche plus
de 65 secondes chez les adultes ça n'est
pas bien mieux puisqu'en entreprises les
employés peinent à se concentrer sur une
seule tâche au-delà de 3 minutes c'est
pas beaucoup qu'est-ce qui a écrit dans
vos mains là il y a écrit je t'aime moi
non plus parce que je suis pas assez
important d'affection non je me suis dit
si j'ai vous savez quoi je flippé non
non en plus tu veux que je te dise c'est
des anti-sèches illisibles donc comme ça
podcast c'est ça non non non alors je
sais très bien comment ça marche
parce que j'ai toujours peur d'oublier
les noms qui ont passé des gens qui ont
passé du temps avec moi et donc on a pas
oublié les noms tout va très bien
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec notre
attention et de rien première raison
évidente c'est internet et les réseaux
sociaux Joanne Harry estime que nous
vivons dans une illusion aujourd'hui
nous pensons en particulier les jeunes
pensent cela qu'on peut multiplier notre
cerveau peut réfléchir à plusieurs
tâches en même temps on peut on pense
qu'on peut travailler tout en envoyant
des textos recevant des textos c'est
absolument impossible selon des
neuroscientifiques américains
éteignez la télé rallumer vos neurones
et voilà et comme le disait Florian
[Rires]
non mais Florian je t'invite gentiment
tu me dis il faut éteindre la télé bravo
Florian et comme je disais Florian c'est
une dérive
notre cerveau peut se concentrer sur une
seule tâche éventuellement de taches
dans le meilleur des cas au-delà nous ne
sommes plus attentifs et notre attention
dépend aussi de notre alimentation de
l'air qu'on respire de notre stress et
ces dernières décennies nourriture
industrielle stress et pollution n'ont
pas fait beaucoup de bien à notre
attention lui a une conduite
parfaitement raisonnable au volant d'une
voiture de golf cette vidéo de 4 minutes
montre un orang-outan conduire dans la
propriété où il vit à Dubaï
l'animal a sans doute été dressé pour
avoir une attitude aussi humaine la
séquence originale a manqué toutefois
d'un petit quelque chose
une bande son ajoutée par un internaute
pour une balade à la cool alors mon tél
porte-parole du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous avez à dire Florian Philippe
je suis content que ça ressuscite cette
affaire monsieur Philippot qui avait
disparu des cas des cadrans donc c'est
pas mal de revoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est que c'est avec sa tiens cette fois
non
on verra plus tard si c'est encore là
bon ben on recommence pas le Melun
s'ouvre demain vous étiez venu là vous
deviez rentrer à 10h madame Chiappa et
non mais bon
priorité au direct bon c'est un bouquin
je n'ai pas lu mais Minecraft
Pascal tout le monde n'a pas son
transférer
bravo
je peux pas vous dire autre chose